welcome pi day to San Francisco very
cool so uh let's talk about some machine
learning I am Randall Shane and this is
closing the machine learning loop in
Python so let's do the abstract let me
jump to the abstract of the abstract
which is very abstract this is about how
to assimilate machine learning into your
architecture / code we have a lot of
things that run these days that are
still waterfall method which means some
data comes in do you do some stuff use
but some things out you're done that is
not a feedback loop that is not how
machine learning works so let's let's
kind of get through it a little bit we
have to we have to include this in our
information we have to develop a
feedback loop into the architecture and
code of what we're actually using cool
my why do I preach this you're welcome
to stalk me on LinkedIn or Twitter or
any of those I stopped to give my email
out because it gets followed by like
seven thousand recruiter calls of take
this job in Wisconsin no so uh oh I've
been doing this a long time I got about
20 years experience unfortunately I'm
getting old but I used to hunt down
cheaters on the stock exchange for a
long time which is fun at a billion
trade to date and try to find people
that are putting across violations
that's always a really neat pattern
matching activity but jump to data
science as it became a thing a few years
ago done for startups three sold one
after I left one catastrophic Lee
imploded at the 91st day it was awesome
when they start building a boxing gym
with VC funds I was like this is going
to be great save us fantastic alright so
that's me so I am the current data
scientist for bodybuilding com we are
located in Boise Idaho you wouldn't like
it there's nothing there don't don't
come there I tell everyone that it's
actually a great great place it's a good
company to work with we're like 31
million uniques a month so we have a
pretty significant audience we have a
combination
an e-commerce play so it's very
interesting I see a lot of weight
lifters in the crowd so if you are wait
Pilar marathon runner bicyclist health
and fitness we have you name it we have
it for you how can I get you into this
supplement today but the reality is we
have a pretty good a very wide site the
difficulty of our site is honestly it
was built in like 2004 so it's built on
a very older ecommerce model which is ok
but it doesn't fit today's model of a
much more personalized experience plus
the width of that site is very different
if you come in and you are a marathon
runner and the first thing you see is
Vaughn mugger who is a dude who's so big
he looks like he ate another dude you're
like this is not for me but the reality
is we have a lot of marathons so how do
I get things to you in a personalized
way we do that with machine learning we
use do that by closing the feedback loop
all right here's my little agenda we're
going to do a what section and a how
section and then we'll walk through a
little code afterwards I'm going to walk
through an example as we do this so it's
a little bit more tangible the example I
want to use here is gender inference
modeling it is very important health and
fitness whether you are male or female
there are significant differences
between the gender so let me let me just
get this out of the way right now women
work twice as hard for half the result
period that is what we find and it is
what we find in data consistently so all
you dudes who are like I can lose 10
pounds in a week yeah of course you can
it's very different for other people and
that changes as you age so it's
interesting to see the correlations and
it's interesting to see what's there
from my standpoint I know that the base
level of personalization is to know your
gender if I know your gender I can start
to get you to the right place next I
need to know your goal so are you trying
to gain weight are you trying to lose
weight and that's actually really easy
there are six women on the planet that
are gaining weight all the rest of them
are losing four men your loot you're
gaining you're going to get huge until
you're thirty one and then you're on the
lose weight
category so again a few exceptions but
that's just generally our health and
fitness is hilarious it's a hilarious
thing to work ins it's just there's so
much really good stuff and I work with a
lot of really smart people and I work
with a lot of bros that are like they
flex all day long it's fantastic all
right the what section so what is
machine learning there's a bunch of
different definitions out there I kind
of like this one and I put my little
credit down here I got it off techtarget
essentially it is any code system that
self improves let's see if you can read
the whole long slide but essentially if
you are writing code that improves
itself you are writing an artificial
intelligence or a machine learning
system you know right and Skynet but it
might get better at certain things so
example this starts our example I want
in for your gender okay the more you
visit the Site the more I collect
information which means the better job I
can do inferring your gender once I know
for sure if you self select now you can
become part of the training set that
says ah you are male you visit these
things you are female you visit these
things I can usually as the training set
so I'm kind of using both sides of it if
I know great you're part of training the
algorithm if I don't know you're part of
working the algorithm all right more of
the what what does this mean for us look
the waterfall days are over I mean the
reality is we need to be smarter
everything has to operate at scale these
days and scale is usually fairly
significant the reality of that is we
pass have to get away from that
waterfall model so the more that we can
use the output of information that we
have and we can use activity that is
generated you can call a crowdsource you
can call it ugc user-generated content i
think there's 5,000 algorithms for this
stuff or acronyms for this stuff you can
use that to help make your code smarter
that's the whole point we want it we
want to use that information back in we
have to think
of every operation we are performing is
more of an opportunity for our machines
to pull in information and gain
knowledge so it's a little change from
the if you've been writing code for a
while the original sort of application
developer is like let's just make it
work it's like yeah that's not enough so
we have to keep track look part of that
keeping track is integrating things like
metric systems knowing what you're
looking for trying to get that
information out the back end so your
activity stream again consistent with
your gender I collect that it helps me
determine who you are if I already know
who you are then you're the other side
of that equation it helps me predict you
somebody else's all right the last of
the what section will say what again
anyone pulp fiction reference ok all
right feedback loops a circular referral
of information output as users perform
as a portion to the input old days i
think i've drawn down enough about that
so i want to collect this activity until
i can confirm gender so if you self
select you set a goal i can confirm it
great now you're part of the your part
of the training set but the other side
of that is i can also do this if I know
that you're the probability of your male
gender is ninety-five percent or the
probability of your female gender is
ninety-three percent I very close enough
that I can slide you over into that
category 31 million people a month it's
difficult to do everyone over and over
and over again the fortune side is we
have a fair retention rate so the people
that I already know I really don't have
to reclassify them what this does is it
reduces the load on how much I have to
compute and how much data i have to have
in there so now i could be a little bit
smarter about the things that i take in
all right that's the end of our what
section the how
you have to plan for improvement so in
the architecture of the way that these
things are built you have to think
through how do I want this information
to work for me what do I want to do how
do I want to design my feedback loop so
it needs to be designed it needs to be
designed as a portion of it one of the
big things i always use centralized
repository for information so with that
said is it possibly redundant data do I
potentially have information that I have
on other people other places yes I
absolutely utterly do but i always put
them in a single repository where i can
get to the information quickly and
easily I've kind of moved away from I've
moved very much away from using
relational databases in production
information and basically my production
environments so I do almost everything
no SQL or I cash it or I do read us or a
dupe or something like that I use a lot
of [ __ ] use a lot of Monaco because
it's free and it's cheap read free and I
like it it's easy to use it's easy to
change and the nice part about [ __ ] to
is it reduces that semantic dissonance
if you have a relational database it's
highly normalized it's very difficult to
look at the base level tables that build
and build and build back up this tree to
come up with information and see
correlations between two base tables
that are two normalizations away you
just it's hard for the human mind to
grasp that in [ __ ] and a large table
environment and something like that the
information is right next to each other
I have tripped over more really good
things in [ __ ] then I would ever have
found in a relational database I mean
I'm super smart and everything's in my
head and of course I can get it all
immediately yeah now I've tripped over a
lot of really good stuff that's humor if
I have to tell you guys that's humor
this going to be a little session all
right so thanks through how to be
analyzed I mean think of your
information you know think through how
you want to see this stuff come in and
think of our example our example here is
pretty simple like I need to have site
activity and I need to know like watch
portions of the site that you're viewing
you know are you looking at
Nation stories are you looking at car
you are you looking at shoulder rehab
like the site sections are very
important so think through those pieces
of the information and plan for it plan
the structure and architecture and code
that you have in a way that makes that
make sense the curse of dimensionality I
love this can you get way too
information too much information yes
absolutely I do not need to track that
you are in any one of 25 thousand
different articles that we have on the
site and we have a great like content
team and they publish like crazy but I
literally cannot have a table that is
25,000 columns wide is my indicator
table but what is important site section
it's important to me what site section
you're that you're in so I can do some
aggregations in that way try to limit
things the other thing too is I try to
limit activity on 120 day basis to me if
you have not been back to our site / you
haven't been hitting the gym or working
out for 120 days you are starting again
so if you think and go back in the gym
and you get to pick up where you left
off you're not you're starting again so
but that's realistic and it works very
well for us it's a very tangible thing
it also limits the amount of data than I
have to have so I start to solve some of
that bulk and some of that
dimensionality problem real time versus
batched so some of these choices get
made for you for example we have a data
warehouse and our data warehouse
collects web tracking information and we
have all these things that we track and
it's all really good and it comes in
once a day I can't really be real time
using that data capture mechanism on a
once a day basis it's not going to
happen so in some ways some of that as a
decision gets made for you the other
side is think through how much of this
do I really need in real time and how
much of this can i patch on the back end
other hybrid approaches to them yes the
example here now I be getting ahead of
myself is I segment customers and the
segmentation I have a customer's you
fall into about 3,500 categories it's
actually 3240 but
sounds wait new specific so in those
3,500 categories what i can do is i can
pre batch the things that should be
provided for each category and i can do
it off a chunk of data and does it
change that much each day not really so
i can do it at night when the
computational speed is not that
important and then I leave the live time
to sort of my computation of who you are
or what the gender is and then once I
get it I just pull the batch data out of
the table and I could push it forward so
you can stage these things together to
bring your computational load down makes
your scale but easier capture monitor
metrics effectively so this is a big
thing it is important to remember
whenever we write stuff we want to keep
track of it look I do stuff by the
numbers so to me I want to try to turn
everything into supervised learning I
want to try to turn it into an empirical
problem if I can see numbers that are
direct metrics correlated with what I'm
doing I know I'm doing well i know i'm
doing that well if i make a change and i
say i'm going to make a change in
recommended products that I send to you
and then on the long end of the
e-commerce conversion funnel I'll look
at the conversion rate and be like oh it
went up I did fantastically there's 25
steps in the process that could have
changed I don't feel like those things
are related enough to be able to provide
me the kind of feedback than I need part
of getting that is to design into your
code how do I get back the things that I
need immediately and for me it is when I
am inferring someone's gender and I have
them inferred in a table I have them
over certain percentage or I just have
them inferred and I haven't moved them
to the I know who you are but they self
select I look at that reconciliation
between the two how accurate have I been
on a days basis in being able to infer
that person's gender and so that helps
me from the standpoint of I'm do better
i'm not doing better and I monitored
daily alright example yes site activity
we feed it real time to an indicator
table so some
our side active activity site activity
we do do real time and stuff to an
indicator table it becomes part of that
classification again I do it on site
section I don't do every single article
just because of that dimensionality
problem i calculate a score I know when
I hit critical mass I know what I need
to be able to make an inference if you
look at two articles I have no idea I
have no idea whatsoever because it'll be
there's von moger here's a hot girl
here's a guy eating a refrigerator and
you're at the end I have no idea who
you're but I know if I get you six or
seven steps down the line and it is a
combination of using tools on the site
you've gone through the find a plan
wizard you've looked at some articles
here and there I've reached critical
mass now i know it's worth the
computational time to pluck you out of
there do the classification on who you
are and then push back into your session
the personalization so i keep that score
calculated and i keep that as part of
what's happening as you're running in
the site itself once triggered course
you know run for classification is
rendered and push the segmentation back
in and I calculate that percentage of
accuracy that's my that's my metric on
this shoot I have thought of using a
Markov chain I actually don't use that
what I do is I do it on a really simple
basis I effectively add that information
to I have your essentially your key in
the table and I add that information
into the table and I know once I pass
seven events I can get yet yeah yeah
yes it would be very nice yeah
absolutely I like the Markov chain idea
where you can kind of change that state
and put people into different things but
it's interesting I mean some of that
really works at scale and some of it
doesn't so we have to 31 million people
a month is a lot to work with so we have
we've issues sometimes with keeping
things running on a smart enough basis
fast enough Oh huge yeah hugely usually
all right more of the ha I will say this
speed is not as important as efficiency
so a lot of our site and I do my I have
a little engine it's called gain it is
the goal achievement intelligence
network get it gained bodybuilding
making gains all right so most of our
site is Java site and I always loved the
Java guys that are like oh pythons like
writing in pseudocode yeah it is that's
why I like it and so it makes the
complicated things simple efficiency is
very important so it's more important to
be efficient in your design than it is
to try to brute force through a whole
bunch of speed do I need to run at the
speed of see mm no I don't I don't is
perfectly fine fast database storage so
again I like [ __ ] a cache stuff I'd use
Redis quite a bit too reticence nice and
easy I mean everybody a Redis user yeah
right is this just I know there's other
stuff out there but it's just the
easiest thing in the world to use it's
so simple so sticks and memory very fast
cues we have activemq which is a very
good little program there's a lot of
good it's a lot of good queuing stuff in
there and is it me or is the celery
library suddenly like I'm here it's
celery has that been around for a while
it's like in the last year i think i've
seen it two dozen times so that's a good
little piece of machinery if you don't
use that for workers that's that's great
that's better than trying to write
multiple so celery works really well
reasonability filtering so try to use
reasonability filtering in the data that
you store the reality is the first time
i sat down a bodybuilding and I dug
through our data warehouse and I pulled
out a whole bunch of people there were a
ton of five-year-olds and there were a
ton a hundred and ten year olds and I
was like wow we have a pretty diverse
audience and I was surprised at how many
people under the age of 7 had a credit
card I did not realize that was a trend
in the US but I was like oh that's very
interesting so that kind of stuff stored
in your data is not helpful but this is
just not helpful to have that so I try
to use reasonability filtering in
anything that stores specifically in
your computational tables you will want
a layer and you will want to abstract
that layer and pull that sort of junk
out as much as you possibly can don't
over collect don't over compute hard to
do hard to do the first time easier to
do 90 days down the road but that's kind
of the process so that's definitely kind
of the process should you try to get to
that sort of tuned point where you have
exactly what you need but not more
knowing computation is going to be
fruitful and that's just a matter of
figuring it out it's just a matter of
you know you model it you put it
together I prototype and are and I do
all my production stuff in Python and I
like our but I once put a recommendation
in an engine in that ran an R and I will
never do that again so I love at the
prototype I love the granularity of it
but I'm kind of a big Python fan for
production stuff so it was it had to be
plugged into an Oracle stack and this is
before Oracle included it in their
actual like interpreter and Oracle
itself and so it had to do this crazy
sort of pull information in from
tables do its thing write them out to a
CSV and then they would pick the CSV
back up and write it in and it was like
what this could only be worse if I was
ft peeing it somewhere so it's just some
of these things are process yeah that's
funny too worked at smaller startups and
I like the smaller environment I like to
build very aggressively and I like to
make changes as needed and it's very
different when you work for a larger
company and it's nice to have the scale
of a larger company and it's nice to be
at startups that grow up a little bit
and you're like hey I'm going to get
paid next week but then you get to that
point where you're kind of like mmm I
can't just on the fly make a whole bunch
of changes and so it becomes a little
bit different I think habit I think
habit is the answer to that so yeah I
just generally prototype in our I think
I feel like in some ways I have more
granularity of control on some of the
algorithms in our although I'm not sure
with like the newer versions of psyche
line if that's really that true anymore
so my answers have it okay engineer the
feedback loop into the system and
implement pre-calculated lookups that's
that whole like 3,500 segments if you're
in segments you know you're 28 year old
male gaining weight your weight Pilar
great here's a whole bunch of things you
should do here's social people you
should hook up with articles you should
read supplements you should look at
workouts you should do etc so pretty
batching that makes it a lot easier a
pretty simple example we're collecting
the events we're adding it to the
indicator table once i hit critical mass
I go ahead and actually do that
personalization and then it just keeps
going to repeat the process until my
interpretation of your gender gets above
a certain level and once it's over a
certain percentage level I pretty much
know once we're over eighty eight
percent I think I'm I think I'm there
so and then once you've got your
threshold almost instant it's almost
instant so after I have the seventh
event it runs the computation usually
runs in milliseconds and then I just
push it back out and push it into your
session and on the next update of
content that comes out which is which is
generally next page it should be there
the second option is you've
self-selected I self-select edge back to
transmit okay you get the idea and this
is another piece of how I try to manage
that scale once I know you once you've
self-selected or I've got over the
eighty-eight percent number and I edge
back into something else I still track
your activity and we still track what
happens and I use that as part of the
training set but I don't need to track
that live time anymore I then let that
flow through the long process and it
goes through the regular web tracking
and it goes into the warehouse and I
pluck them out of the warehouse it's the
next day it kind of deal fine but I
already know you are so it's not
critical for me to get to that point so
I move it to more of a passive
collection versus that off the bat to
try to get you the right spot that's my
active collection all right a little
more of the how so the architecture code
section tests that training set to
evaluate accuracy again I do try to make
everything supervised learning as much
as I can so once i have it that way i
have some idea of i have a number i can
focus on and i can actually work with if
its empirical it makes it a lot easier I
look for outliers during prototyping and
it helps me to kind of clip things off
you know there's a number of different
ways to do this is inferential
statistics there's great outliers the
couple great outliers libraries out
there one of the really simple ones that
i like is two or three times standard
deviation from the
so and that's my little standard
deviation graph so you're really just
kind of cutting off point three percent
maybe you're cutting off four percent it
depends on how dirty your data is I'll
be honest our data is we have so much of
it so i used to a bodybuilding I've used
three other places that's a really
simple way to just kind of get the highs
and lows out stage data categorically
and use appropriately this in our
example is a lot of that using site
section try to use the Site sections
appropriately I try to avoid grain of
sand size of Jupiter this person read
two articles there's a person read 95
articles fine but oftentimes I don't
like to see that kind of variance in my
data so i choose a log scale just the
Richter scale just put it on log 10 it
will bring it down and we'll bring
everything to a much more normalized way
to work with you can I often have to do
this first so i have to kind of cut some
outliers off and then once the outliers
are cut off you usually get into a
fairly decent place i am also very
partial to tree based methods and i
think they do a better job with more
real-time data just in that way and so i
have a great love of the random forest
it's just it's just so robust I mean it
doesn't matter like how far off a lot of
the stuff is yo it still seems to come
out pretty consistently so I use a bunch
of I always try to use multiple methods
so again I am a huge fan of tree methods
but I will always try to model in a
number of different ones I keep thinking
to myself I'm going to model something
in and I am going to find some obscure
method out there and it's going to be
the perfect thing it never is and I want
to use random forest like ninety-eight
percent of the time but the point is
that I always in my head is try
something else
try something different if nothing else
then for the experience of trying
something different and having the
experience of walking through it and see
why it does what it does method
averaging is a really nice thing
ensemble methods is a nice thing
population splitting if you could figure
out which populations work better with
which methods that's a nice way to do it
a lot of this has to do with just taking
the time sit down with the information
you have broader time through it get it
running and then iterate your efforts
the first effort is never perfect it's
like all those people that proclaim that
they are these artful programmers and
they write these beautifully executed
codes the first time and the program is
all put together I do not know any of
those programmers and I am a horrible
typist so when I write stuff the first
time I go to run it it's like literally
I have to go through 25 typing errors
and in my head is like I should learn to
type I don't think it would help me go
better so I don't but it's just one of
those things so but iterate your efforts
the more you iterate your efforts and
the more you go through more you start
to gain that understanding of this is
why this did this this would work better
this is more appropriate here and it
helps you to kind of make those
decisions like should I split my
population and use different algorithms
to get there lastly manga runtime and
load metrics absolutely there's a lot of
ways to do this there's a lot of tools
for that stuff there's a lot of
third-party tools there's like dated dog
and zabbix and there's hundreds of these
things out there I if probably used the
same silly little method that I've used
for years and years and it's just BS
utility library and I just pluck some
stuff out of psu till and I just jam it
into a table and I can see while things
are running what memory looks like what
my computational load looks like it
makes it really simple that's an easy
one and then you know time time it use
asymptotic notation when you write that
kind of thing all right
keeping track implement metrics to
monitor progress if you do not have
metrics in there to monitor progress you
do not know if while you're going
through it you think to yourself you
know if I know this item I will know
exactly how this is doing you should
write that item in their period it
should be in there figure out a way to
track it get it in you have to implement
metrics I feel like I'm preaching to the
choir when I talk to application
programmers and they're like oh no no
we'll put it in afterwards no we'll do
it now let's do it up front that's much
more of a fight and established
companies that's much less of a fight at
a start-up this seems to be more of
understanding of that I was designed
with metrics in mind I pick one two
three don't try to be like I'm going to
check 50 things don't do that don't do
that because what's going to happen is
two of those things are going to be at
odds with each other and they will be at
odds for a differing reason and then you
will doubt one of them and you will
inevitably doubt the one that is
important to you that's just how
murphy's law works so pick one two three
try to put them in there don't over
track the stuff just get a simple idea
of what's happening again direct
associations important iterate efforts
without a doubt and do it by the numbers
don't ever feel like it's better if you
feel like it's better just you bumped
your head don't do that they're put
numbers to it it should be better
empirically example very simple monitor
classification by day I look at the
classification the training set that's
there I look at the accuracy of
confirmed people that are there so I do
the test set training set I tell then I
look at my test set I look at people
that have self selected after the point
that I've already classified them and
that gives me a decent sense of how I'm
doing keep calculating over and over
again and prototypes your best result
etc all right
more the how here's what is not
important it is not important to have
the same attribute in a table twice
because one of them will tell you what
two of them will tell you and I'm
shocked at the number of times I look at
any analytics metrics tracking any of
those systems I look at data and it's
exactly that like what it doesn't make
any sense to me so try to get those
things pull those things off even if you
have individual and unique indicators if
you want to say on these features which
ones are really important a couple ways
to find out ki prototyping on your
information see what's there I always
look at like attribute importance that
comes out and so i'll look at which
attributes it sees are very important in
which attribute disease are unimportant
which I've made a decision as to what to
use if I pull a few of the unimportant
ones out do I still get the same thing
what if i take the most important one
out then what does it tell me this is
part of the prototype process this is
just kind of part of what I go through
and what's there if you find two
features that are directly correlated
with each other your correlation values
like point eight eight you can probably
just pick one of those and it depends if
you have 25 columns of information 25
fields in your indicator table it's
probably not going to make any
difference if you've 150 yeah and
probably make a difference probably
easier to start pairing that down yeah
use common sense I mean some of the
stuff just doesn't doesn't fit anything
I'm eliminate duplicates don't ever
track again prototype with relevant past
experience okay so I try to put a
prototype with blocks of data that makes
sense for example in health and fitness
there is huge seasonality January
everybody's going to get fit April
everybody's going to get a beachbody
November I'm going to eat December every
year every year though found so if I
want a prototype on stuff and I want to
prototype in August because I want to
get
some stuff in and start getting it
moving for the January push pick up
January's date from last year don't pick
up August data from this year it is
completely different so try to get a
relevant data set that's their time
series decomposition is very helpful in
figuring out trend seasonality and
randomness we have three hugely hugely
random days Black Friday is a huge
random day cyber monday is a huge random
day and we have a birthday bash on the
founding date of the company every year
and it will literally be this huge like
random spike in activity and all kinds
of pull those out just pull that stuff
out that's not it's not going to help
you so try to get decent relevant data
as much as you can use existing tracking
you know try to it's kind of nice when
something's already plumbed I think
that's about 50 50 sometimes that works
really well and sometimes that doesn't
one of the things I think a lot of
companies suffer from though is my sixth
point I want it all we're going to
collect everything Oh weakens me to me
that is an excuse for I have no idea
what I'm going to do with this and I
have a couple my most favorite quotes I
know there's value in that data we just
have to find it yeah that's usually fine
followed by data storage is cheap okay
give me your personal credit card i'm
going to put the AWS bill on it you'll
watch backpedaling like there is no
tomorrow here's what I promote turn it
all on turn every piece of it on collect
everything you want to collect and in 90
days we're going to sit down and look at
that information and when we find in 90
days that you have one percent signal in
ninety nine percent noise we're
concerned ninety-nine percent off of
that of that off because it's getting
ridiculous yeah I was at a I was at a I
just did some contract work at a company
and they tracked 612 things on each
webpage
612 pieces on each page they had
literally billion line tables in sequel
server I was like oh my god look that's
something in queryable I don't know what
you would do with that and it was on but
it's cheap and we already have the
architecture or blood okay look you know
how much of that was important there
were like three metrics that were
actually important that they were
tracking just over over over tracking
but we have all this rich data that's
you only have good data if it's
actionable and worth something you don't
have good data if you have a giant
puddle that's a mess so my thing is kind
of let's not collect the mess 90 days
let's test it out let's try to keep
what's important okay so none correlate
data types a drum for my example i get
rid of duplicates you can permute stuff
together you can streamline calculate
accuracy okay I think I beat all this
stuff to that all right questions it's
far so good all right training set test
set here's how it works most of you
already know this for us we have known
customers with genders no problem then
we have activity for those people and
that activity forms an indicator table
that in that indicator table since i
already have your gender i have your
known outcome that's my training table i
can use that to train my classification
method I feel like where is it I do cam
okay so test set portion of the training
set you clip that baby off and you
essentially already know but if i use my
trained algorithm and i apply to my test
set since i already know i can see how
well my algorithm does against the dated
i already have and that's simple
training set Tessa that's it's very very
basic so that's how we do it here's how
my feedback loop works in production you
come to the site perform some stuff do
things are happening here's where the
loop is kind of in I'm
collecting information as it's moving
forward I already have this sort of on
the side collection of people that I
know the classification is live I apply
that segmentation you self select I get
your over-classification line you get
dropped into that sort of passive table
that I can use to retrain on the
following piece but it's designed in as
part of it and then once we push that in
and personalize your experience all
right let's see some code sure oh so
we're just now putting in an ad stack
like literally we have not put an ad
stack in before so we're just getting to
that point where we're kind of starting
to monetize content so we have typically
been and it's still true content is free
workouts are free there's a bike was
built in that day of Oh we'll build our
own social network so we have like a
little social fitness network that's all
all that stuff's free and then the
content and articles were starting to
put advertising on to monetize those and
then we have ecommerce so we've tons and
tons of supplements
yes yes so what will happen is that
inference modeling will push into the
DMP the demand management platform and
then that supplies the segmentation
audiences that can come from the other
from the like programmatic bidding
portion of it so in any of the ad stuff
you have essentially most of the ad
companies we're actually going to use
crux and they're actually really good
they have a pretty wide cookie that
gives interests age demographic data
gender all that kind of stuff but then
you also push in first-party data so
will push in the first party stuff that
we know as well we will eventually so
all that together it is specifically
from the standpoint that we have a high
volume of customers that come in every
month that we don't know who they are
and so while the wider purview of the
cookies you get from an ad platform are
very useful oftentimes you cannot pull
that information back out and use it
first party so if I wanted to use the ad
platforms cookie based segmentation to
do like product recommendations I would
have to essentially serve my products as
if I was serving an ad zone as you can't
to pull it they frown on you pulling
stuff backward out of their platform
um we don't go that far I mean we could
but we we don't go that far the one
thing we will do is we'll put a pop-up
hey sign up for our deals we have you
know deals percent off free shipping
that kind of stuff and as part of that
it's yours your email address use your
gender give us your goal and so we'll
ask what we don't we don't go don't go
too far with it we try to do we try to
do it the right way look we really do we
really concentrate on trying to make it
not creepy and you know we're just
trying to get the right stuff in front
of you so the data that you're
collecting is from clicks on your site
there are questions how is there any
data that exists that's alistate like a
factor that you can't collect you don't
know what it's like a dimension to the
data cloud that you have that you cannot
get directly from the data that I would
say yes so we have combination of we ask
questions and then there's things like
widgets on the site that you go through
if you're going through find a plan to
figure out what workout plan you should
do and there are other things that we
infer like if you're buying all female
based products their site activity there
are things that we don't know where we
try to infer and intent is a big one so
you can look at someone who is looking
at like shoulder or knee recovery and
they're looking at a lot of recovery
type things but it's are you looking at
this because you've had an injury are
you looking at this because you have
like weak knees are you looking at this
because your marathon runner like how
does
how did the sort of fit so the question
becomes do we have a recovery category
or is it a subcomponent of something
else and there are compelling stories
both ways how do we determine like who's
whether they're enough you know like
saying the first year operating your
site that there was a category called
not even knowing that was a site section
and you can see it over and over when
you look at things like tagged articles
and we take articles and we tag like the
use of supplements or that kind of thing
so I know if you're taking a lot of like
chicken cartilage and glucosamine and
you're reading shoulder recovery
articles that's very much in this sort
of genre of it so it becomes inferred
from other data that's there so that's
your question what it seems like there
had to be a human who look at it and
made a decision like you know maybe
using some dimensional reduction or
something like that and and you're like
oh this new factor this is recovery
because I know what people do that's I
can figure it out so you need a human to
look at that yeah that's part of
prototyping a lot of this comes out as
we prototype data it's hard to get a
machine to interpret all those things
cool any other questions all right true
wat some code run that's always fun all
right so here's my here's just a little
clip of my model essentially
alright so start to run through got my
read time I do a little transform and
save part of that transform and save
routine is coming up with things that
are important like it's interesting that
refer actually well that's not gonna
work yeah
huh
okay that's a weird thing
hey there we go all right so we run
through I do little reading my
information I do my little transform and
save some of the transformation also is
just getting categorical information off
things like refer site section we're
going to turn it into a number some of
those numbers are ordinal some of those
numbers are just indicator numbers that
are there and then we start to run
through the classification I split my
training and test set so is what 65,000
so yeah it's about 45 and 20 about 70 30
is usually what I use when there are
arguments to other numbers use which are
comfortable with I'm going to run three
different algorithms here random forest
gradient descent and nearest neighbor so
trains that algorithm up in just about
45 seconds and there's my test set I
lived through my test set and
classification time on that took about
20 seconds and then I grade myself and
so random force about seventy nine
percent then 78 on nearest neighbor 70
on gradient descent by method average
Emma see that brings it down a little
bit and maybe that certain audiences are
specifically better under one algorithm
than another but that's generally how I
run through it and my code looks like
our wheel okay so this is PI [ __ ] and
then these are coming onto scikit-learn
library here's my it's my connection
stuff here's my little look up on refer
and here's my little prep so I go
through and I go through the different
site sections that we have do a little
cleaning out and let's see a little
validity check and make sure we have
information is my transformation and
then I do a little decider on test or
train once decided I run through my
classification
and so it runs through trains my
algorithms you notice i have attribute
importance for random force commented
out at the moment i generally put that
back in i think that's probably an
argument for prototyping with python
also and then we just kind of run
through I do my probabilities and my
predictions and then I blend that stuff
together so I have a little a little
method average in there and then I just
grade myself and just print it out at
the boss thank you I appreciate